(applaudissements)
- Pas question pour lahahahahahc
Solidaire dans Sherbrooke.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre
- Ça nous pndndndndndndndndndnd.
- Cette candidate,
c'est Caroline St-Hilaire,
ex-députée du bloc québécois, m.
CAROLINE ST-HILAIRE, candidate
de la CAQ dans Sherbrookerereret
très fort et ça a réveillé
quelque chose. Alors, c'est
pour ça que j'ai accepté de
venir servir ici à Sherbrolelelé
sortante de Québec Solidaire,
ririristine Labrie.
CHRISTINE LABRIE, députée et
candidate, QS, Sherbrooke
la crise du logement, la crise
environnementale. C'est de
ça dont on va parler. Donc,
peu importe la candidature
de la CAQ, ça ne change
des gens de Sherbrooke.
- La lutte s'annonce rude.
Christine Labrie a été nommée
étoile montante par ses pairs
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Elle s'est démarquée par
sa pugnacité sur les enjeux
de l'éducation et la famille.
sa connaissance fine de
la politique tant fédérale
que municipale est un atout
majeur qui la rend ministrable.
MICKAËL BERGERON, chror,r,r,r,
"La Tribune"
- Pendant 2022, Christine Labrie
a mené dans les inte'e'e'e'e'e't
une des rares places au Québec
qui résistait, seueueueut dire,
à la Coalition avenir Québec,
mais là les intentions viennent
de se ressgagagagagagagagagagag.
- Peu connue dans la région,
Carot-t-t-t-Hilaire aura
plusieurs défis.
- Elle devra démontrer,
papapapapapapapapapapapapapapape
maintenant dans la région, mais.
Montrer ses racines du côté
de l'Estrie et aussi
effectivement, quelle est
son expérience politique.
- Surtout, convaincre
les électeurs.
engagée. Aussi, je sais
qu'elle est très ai
au niveau des étudiants.
- Je pense que madame Labrie
va revenir.rerererererererereree
trop fort, ils vont faire
ce qu'ils
- Le Parti québécois
et le Parti vert ont déjà
présenururururururururururururus
partis se font encore attendre.
utututututut porte à croire que
ce sera un duel : la CAQ
contre Québec Solidair